entendez ça moi je crois que ça c'est un
signe que c'est l'heure de vous montrer
un effet de tracking sans plugin sur
find the cut mais après l'intro bien sûr
[Musique]
il salue légendaire écran c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mme encore je
suis ravi d'avoir trouvé comme
d'habitude sur cette chaîne où on parle
de vidéos de montage de captation tout
ça tout ça
donc si c'est des sujets qui vous
plaisent n'hésitez pas à vous abonner il
ya sûrement des choses qui vont vous
plaire sur cette chaîne aujourd'hui on
parle comme vous l'avez vue d'un effet
plutôt sympa de tracking d'objets dans
final cut
alors le tracking en gros ça va
consister à suivre le mouvement d'un
objet dans un plan pour donner
l'impression que la caméra elle est
carrément vissé à l'objet en question et
accentuer le mouvement
alors bien entendu il existe des plugins
il existe aussi des façons de faire dans
after effect mais là on s'occupe de
final cut
et puis les plugins que j'ai trouvé pour
faire cet effet là m'ont pas forcément
convaincu par ce que il y avait des
moments l'intelligence artificielle
perdez l'objet qu'on suivait donc il
fallait à retoucher à la main etc etc
du coup autant le faire à la main autant
le faire sans plugin et sans débourser
un centime
et oui jean michel à côté bien entendu
sur after effet qu'il ya des moyens
d'automatiser la chose mais sur cette
chaîne
on parle principalement de final cut
voilà et bien entendu avant de commencer
je rappelle que trop d'effets tu les
fais un c'est en effet à placer avec
parcimonie et quand ça se prête à votre
scénario quand ça ajoute un de plus un
bien entendu ça servirait à rien de
placer cet effet tout le temps dans une
vidéo on est bien d'accord donc c'est
partir entrons donc dans le vif du sujet
tout d'abord il faut penser à la
captation comment est-ce qu'on a filmé
ses plans et bien tout simplement déjà
on les a filmés en 4k parce qu'on va
devoir jouer dans l'image on va devoir
cros paix dans l'image donc si on filme
seulement en 1080p on risque d'avoir pas
mal de déperdition et une image dégradée
alors qu'en quatre cas on pourra
exporter facilement en 1080 en full hd
il y aura pas de souci donc première
chose à faire la 4k ensuite ensuite
ensuite ensuite bien entendu ce sont des
plans qui ont été filmées à la main
s'était pas sur trépieds donc il faut
aussi essayer de suivre un maximum le
sujet un l'objet qui est en mouvement
avec votre caméra alors l'idéal par
exemple sur la prise ou the lancet
l'autre joue bien je les lancer
plusieurs fois et marie suivait le
mouvement est pas forcément sur les 10
ce qu'on a fait il y en avait forcément
une bonne et on essayait de garder
surtout un rythme pour pouvoir être
synchro entre la personne qui lance
l'objet est celle qui filme donc
vraiment toujours 1 2 3 4 1 2 presque en
musique c'était voilà c'était pas très
très compliqué une fois qu'on a ça filmé
en 4k et avec le mouvement de caméra qui
va bien le raid se passe dans le
logiciel de montage
ok j'ai donc pris ce plan dans la
timeline et c'est sur ce plan là qu'on
va travailler en premier
alors ici je veux dire le plan on a tout
simplement le déplacement de la caméra
ici sur le plan de travail avec un
mouvement de caméra qui va avec
est ce qu'on va faire c'est accentuer
encore plus ce mouvement de caméra pour
garder vraiment la caméra ici au centre
de l'image pour placer la caméra au
centre de l'image sans problèmes et être
sûr de son coup
il ya un outil dans présentation qui
s'appelle affiché l'horizon et la magie
on sait exactement où se trouve le
centre de l'image
et on voit que justement notre caméra
ébahis si elle est un petit peu décalé
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est se placer
au tout début
ici on va réduire la taille ici de notre
visualiseur parce qu'on va devoir jouer
en remettre à 50% par exemple et on va
aller cliquer ici sur l'outil transformé
on va cliquer sur le bouton de qui frame
ici pour que chaque modification qu'on
va faire ici image par image soit
memories alors ici on va vous mais un
petit peu pour avoir de la marge et
placer notre caméra ici le capteur tout
pile au centre
voilà je vais ensuite avant cette image
par image alors voyez qu'ici c'est un
tout petit peu décalé voilà image par
image avec les flèches de notre gauche
et de droite si je vais revenir en
arrière
hop et on va vraiment essayer d'être
hyper précis et de garder toujours le
centre de l'image vraiment au milieu du
capteur donc c'est un petit peu
fastidieux comme opération mais le rendu
est quand même plutôt sympa là et donc
si on lit ici notre notre image
on est bon on aurait peut-être même pu
zoomer encore un peu plus pour accentuer
l'effet me faut pas non plus il ya les
trop c'est un petit peu too much
maintenant on va regarder un autre plan
parce que ici on a fait un déplacement
vous allez voir qu'on peut faire aussi
des rotations donc ça peut être sympa
alors je vais pas vous leur faire parce
que ça prendrait trop de temps et que
vous avez compris l'idée mais ici sur ce
plan je vais appuyer sur contrôle v pour
afficher ici l'animation vidéo et voyez
qu à des qit frame un petit peu partout
ici donc il ya du zoom et il ya de la
rotation ce que j'ai fait ici tout
simplement c'est faire tourner l'image
alors j'ai penché la tête comme ça tout
simplement mais ce que j'ai fait c'est
de faire en sorte que ici la ligne
verticale soit toujours à la verticale
sur mon visage
ce qui fait qu'en fait on a l'impression
que la caméra suit le mouvement et s'est
donné un petit effet ma foi fort
sympathique pour la rotation et je fais
juste d'agripper ce petit bouton qui
vous permet de faire tourner un petit
peu l'image à savoir que si jamais on
déborde un petit peu et qu'on a un coin
noir ça peut se rattraper aussi avec
l'effet de letter boxe ce qui veut dire
que vous avez quand même pas mal de
marge
surtout si vous avez filmé en 4 capes
autre chose moi j'ai fait le choix de
filmer en 25 images par seconde à 1 50e
pour conserver le flou de mouvement qui
donne un petit effet aussi qui accentue
un petit peu le mouvement si vous ne
voulez pas ce flou de mouvement c'est
très simple il suffit de régler votre
vitesse d'obturation à un centième voire
même un 200e saïd minera tout le flou de
mouvement
moi j'aime bien quand c'est flou de
mouvement quand même et voilà les amis
c'est tout pour ce premier tuto de
l'année 2020
je suis ravi de repartir encore une fois
toujours dans ce nouveau décor est trop
cool et si cette vidéo vous a plu vous
pouvez mettre le traditionnel coup deux
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo
si c'est pas déjà fait vous pouvez
également vous abonner vous pouvez
commenter me laisser votre avis sur cet
effet et puis moi je vous dis comme
d'habitude les amis reste est curieux et
à très bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
tôt le seul petit souci c'est que je ne
peux plus aller mettre ma main sur
l'objectif pour faire le truc de la fin
de d'habitude donc si vous avez des
idées de faim voilà parce que parce que
voilà je sais pas de show salue un bail
au pis voilà enfin j'ai pas défini
encore c'était bien ou alors je fais
juste mais j'ai la grosse baleine